[Music]
you can't really teach someone to be a
lowrider you just live and breathe it
a lot of people associate lowriders with
the car hoppers which is what you see on
TV or at a car show you know on these
cars and get off the high off the ground
and there's the cars like mine we just
proved low to the ground I like to
cruise low and slow
my name is Ruby Ramirez and I'm also
known as King Mona I'm a part of the
Khalifa's car club and the staff is
fellow rider Council and I'm just a girl
of slow light a lot of people will get
really surprised like this is your car
people think the car is my husband's no
it's my car I wanted my car to say our
badass [ __ ] Ching gonna means badass
[ __ ]
so my car is a 1950 Chevy Fleetline
originally was all blue it just wasn't
me I just drew what I wanted down on
paper and lay down some patterns and
with everyone's help
we got my vision from paper to the
streets and now it's cruising everywhere
in the lowrider community there are very
few women there's clubs that don't allow
females and it sucks there's some female
car clubs out there I myself don't want
to be in the off female car club because
I want to show that we can be with the
big boys too
we shouldn't separate ourselves because
we're already separated but they have
categories are female only and why why
can't we be right there with the guys
why can't we compete with the guys
[Music]
I've heard a lot of people you know I've
seen you and your inspiration so that's
pretty cool
I wish everyone can get behind the wheel
and experience cruising the lowrider
there's a lot of women out there that
want to be a part of this and either
they don't know how or they just don't
have someone to give them a kick so
hopefully they see me and we can
continue to bring this into the future
you